é oi então não fosse uma coisa que eu
queria falar muito tempo mas sei lá
aonde o motivo é agora eu tenho muito
espaço no namoro sobre relacionamento
amor e da babá das coisas muita gente me
pediu para falar sobre isso muita gente
em bi ao estrelato sabe falar não sei
que isso é o que lá vai ser fácil para
todos a falar com o povo e eu não sei
por onde começar a falar isso aqui
porque quando você fala sobre namoro
sobre relacionamentos escurecidos e
procura uma pessoa que é bem amiga sua
pra você ter certeza que ela vai falar
para ninguém que você está sofrendo por
causa de outra pessoa para todo mundo
sofre por amor não é para ninguém falar
sem ninguém com essas coisas sentimento
difícil é quem vai falar é não amarrar e
para os fracos não tira mais forte com
os fracos são aqueles caras de 20 anos
sai de noite para pegar nenhum idoso
está triste né é diferente hoje está
chorando que você está assim um cara
esse é o tipo de pergunta você quer
morrer junto com a sua bem lá e não quer
que faça pra você porque você vai ter
que confessar para aquela pessoa que
perguntou pra você você está assim por
causa de uma pessoa a pessoa falar ah
vai não vai fazer merda de novo não
aprende que não aprende né namoram com
fulano deu certo no amor um neutrão deu
certo 80 lá pra que só vai se machucar
amiguinho colega parceiro cheguei lá
esconder ninguém máquina do sofá do euro
é um problema na família no emprego tá
doendo tá doente sofre por amor quando
ele está no elenco
agora me diz qual deve ser a mais
interessante você que vai ter muita
gente vai discordar vai falar que queria
jogar no domingo mas eu preferia da oca
lógico você sofre vai você se diverte
você aprende alguma coisa pelo menos
você beija alguém a não ver se a tata
falando sei que ele gosta de sofrer
lá é tão me diz quantas vezes já não
falou assim ah depois desse aqui eu não
vou falar mais nunca mais nunca uma
semana aí namorando se derretendo parece
um pouco a vida não me término de namoro
é uma merda eu lembro do meu primeiro
amor meu primeiro amor à pessoa eu gosto
de verdade assim sabe pela primeira vez
foi a 8ª série de nove ou não vou falar
o nome dela aqui as iniciais são assim e
não é assim
é como se fosse hoje esse tempo não
tinha um fit uma mensagem toda hora não
tinha internet rápida para tocar aí não
tinha facebook para da indireta não
tinha podem ela na cartinha manda
cartinha o office onde muita calma eu
sou muito vigiada era muito é muito puro
vai com a academia 1º b admitiu não
atividade descobriu e aí a gente teve
que terminar meu irmão meu irmão eu
fiquei muito muito mal sabe o que quer
terminar com a menina que você deu o
primeiro beijo o primeiro beijo também
morreu com 9 ana baseado em experiência
própria
vai tomar no c esse forno culpa da [ __ ]
e sempre tem aquela coisa de achar a
pessoa certa e aí pessoal está certo é
achar a pessoa certa que só pode
escolher essa [ __ ] nunca encontra eu
tenho uma teoria de que você sempre se
ferra na parte do achar alguma coisa da
sua relação ao explicar com seu filho
como menina e aí você começa a gostar
dela e aí você passa um tempo com ela e
aí você acha poder o que vai dar certo
atua com fulano já tem um tempinho já eu
acho poder que ela é uma menina na minha
vida eu acho o deus que é a pessoa certa
para mim eu acho poder o que eu amo
adversário na minha opinião na parte do
achar alguma coisa da sua relação um
universo alguma coisa que está por trás
disso tudo fala assim vai ficar com ela
não não e aí nessa hora a menina que
você apostou tudo no mundo é que você
dava carinho à amiga que você falava no
celular o dia inteiro à música que você
estava toda a atenção do mundo termina
com você peça fala [ __ ] me fugir de
novo acho que aquela coisa do término do
namoro é aquela ausência sabe que você
fala cara ela não vai mandar a mensagem
também não vou mandar
talvez ela estava na casa dela falando
cara ele não vai mandar a mensagem que
eu também não vou mandar e aí fica
aquela coisa muito eu sei dois e você
fica pensando que ela não gosta de você
e ela pensando que você não gosta de
você
aí você fica pensando que ela não gosta
de você e ela fica pensando que você
gosta dela fica aquela ausência que ele
fã cil cara falar uma coisa quem muito
se ausentam hora deixe de fazer falta
chega uma hora que a pessoa falar quem
não quer falar comigo
também não vou correr tarde e aí ela vai
deixar de gostar de você é qualquer
chance que que vocês voltarem e é aí que
surge uma coisinha muito irritante pra
vocês mulheres é o chamado homem que não
presta e é um homem que não presta
qualquer do homem que não presta se eu
falar uma coisa para vocês mulheres
baseado em experiência própria e
observam alguns relacionamentos sabe
aquele cara que tipo namora com três
meninos de um salvei aquele cara que
parece que não tem sentimento ficar com
o nosso deus como é que pode esperar
desse jeito vai pois é esse cara levou
um pé na bunda tão grande de uma menina
que falou assim beleza jacques e
certinho dá certo já que dá carinho e
amor a atenção não dá certo vou fazer o
mal nessa [ __ ] e ó cara fala olha aí
quem é esse cara de uma pessoa tipo
totalmente diferente do que lhe era caro
estou falando isso porque eu já vi uma
pessoa se transformar assim sabe de um
cara super super legal um cara que
brinca com a municipalidade sapato dela
sério é [ __ ] eu não tenho esse estilo de
vida porque eu percebi que esse tipo de
pessoa ou ele morre num acidente ou ele
sai de noite para pegar tipo três
meninas que soma na idade de todas elas
não dá 30 da ele pega tipo 15 minutos
que michel de amor por ele sai porque
não pega a posição da universidade
ele é humano por 15 minutos e odiado por
15 mulheres viu de você fala vale a pena
mas de novo pode apenas centrar uma
coisa que você sabe que talvez nem em
média o lógico que valem essa é a graça
título fosse fácil todo mundo nascesse
pré destinado a ficar com a pessoa certa
olha q bosta que 116 cv tem que apostar
mesmo sem saber o next vai dar
tem que correr risco é que tem que ver o
que dá essa é a graça do amor é
imprevisível o amor é totalmente
imprevisível talvez você deva estar
sofrendo por amor por que você tá
deixando de procurar o melhor para você
ou então você vai deixando passar pela
pessoa que é
e você de verdade então caras o maior
presente que deus pra gente foi a mulher
então trate ela bem em casa e mulheres
por favor não tornem os homens homens
que não prestam é melhor pra gente é
melhor pra você e para o mundo tão por
favor clique aqui e gostei eu te ajudei
alguma coisa se você gostou desse vídeo
se você curte um álbum parte desse vídeo
se você está no facebook compartilhe
esse vídeo se você está no youtube
favorite esse vídeo vai ajudar muito vai
me ajudar vai lhe ajudar vai ajudar seus
amigos ajudar muita gente
eu acho que se você não está inscrito em
nenhum canal é só você que está aqui em
cima inscrever se e aí toda vez que
tiver um videozinho novo vai aparecer aí
pra você eu acho de novo então é isso aí
muito obrigado você quer assistir esse
vídeo e falou